Zaatari has grown from a camp to a city
with more than 80,000 residents streets
and a supermarket customers don't pay
with vouchers but with debit cards each
refugee over the age of 15 gets twenty
seven euros per month from the world
food program automatically loaded onto
their card well goose michalis any ahead
we need more than simply something to
eat so sometimes we sell our food so we
can buy other things the hottie I'm
gonna hide ya through it Danny many have
lived here for over a year and a half
now and for them the camp is no longer a
temporary solution German aid is funding
the construction of a water treatment
plant among other infrastructure still
life in a camp remains harsh as a result
the vast majority of Syrian refugees
have settled in urban areas straining
local infrastructure the international
community should focus on this helping
to relieve socio economic tensions fewer
refugees are being allowed to settle in
sitari the World Food Program is
continuously struggling to maintain its
current support German Foreign Minister
frank-walter Steinmeier has promised
further German support for za'tari but
he says the international community has
a responsibility to do more yet the moon
and intact llegan we hope that now the
United States and Russia have shown a
tentative willingness for renewed
dialogue with Arabic partners will also
back a new international initiative in
its active amid tagging the way home
from za'tari is not far for these
refugees just 10 kilometers through the
desert and they're at the Syrian border